Welcome back everyone this is my avengers 5
video marvel revealed a first look at part of
the roster of the new team with the people that
are going to be in that movie new characters from
marvel phase 4 a bunch of new costumes for
some of the returning characters like thor
and some references to how they're treating the
legacy characters who have died or gone away in
the mcu like iron man and steve rogers captain
america if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're doing a
giveaway for disney plus memberships all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and let me know
which other brand new characters from marvel phase
4 that they're introducing you want to see on that
next avengers team or in avengers 5. i'm mostly
going to focus on the brand new characters the new
costumes during this but obviously they're going
to be a billion characters in that next avengers
film but you've probably been hearing recently
that avengers 5 seems like it's going to turn into
an actual full-blown secret wars multiverse movie
we'd all assume that they do eventually but i
didn't expect that to happen till like avengers 6
so no complaints here i would love to see a secret
wars movie clearly we've seen during marvel phase
4 so far with all the multiverse movies they've
started to set up secret wars spider-man no way
home with them breaking the multiverse then kind
of fixing it fixing it with magical flex tape
We have doctor strange multiverse of madness
where they're going to break reality even more
break the multiverse even more ant-man 3 quantum
mania with kang the conqueror and the loki series
with the kang multiverse war so you don't need
to be a genius to see that they're setting up
secret wars for the next avengers film but if you
saw a version of this first look preview in your
feed the past week this is just part of what the
new avengers roster is going to be in avengers 5
and when i say new roster there's going to be the
new core avengers team which usually has anywhere
from like six to ten members then there's a bunch
of other side characters and heroes who are in
the avengers movies but aren't themselves like
core avengers characters so this preview here
that somebody thankfully took a picture of even
though it clearly says no pictures is of some of
the characters who will be in that next avengers
movie as you can also tell this picture cuts off
a bunch of people like there's a bunch of people
over on the left side of the frame that you can't
see that are cut off and a bunch of people on
the right side of the frame that are cut off
like you can see the person who's going to become
the new version of black panther standing halfway
in frame with a slightly different black panther
suit than the one born by t'challa before he died
and i know spider-man is front and center here
in his iron spider suit despite the fact at the
end of spider-man no way home dr octopus first
demolishes the iron spider suit then gives back
his nanites and they form the new integrated suit
it after doctor strange performed that second
spell and everyone forgets peter parker he cuts up
the integrated suit for scraps and uses those to
create his brand new suit based on the classic
comic book blue and red suit like a cloth suit
so theoretically the iron spider suit should not
exist but i think the reason it's depicted here
and some of the characters have their new costumes
but some of them look like the older versions of
the characters like you have thor here wearing
his new rune king thor costume that he'll get
during thor love and thunder next to jane foster
in her thor costume that she's getting in thor 11
thunder is because when they made this picture
they'd already decided how some of the future
characters would look some of the costumes would
look in the marvel phase 4 movies but they hadn't
finished figuring out exactly what the designs of
spider-man's new suit would be because they have
to work with sony on that and they hadn't figured
out what some of these other characters are going
to look like in their future movies and some of
these characters will have sequels before avengers
5. don't worry i'll talk about the full marvel
phase 4 and marvel phase 5 schedules because
we know what all the marvel movies are going to be
through 2025 but like spider-man for example we're
going to see spider-man 4 before avengers 5 comes
out and is his tradition spider-man always gets
a big suit upgrade in every movie so i think when
they made this mural they were just like just put
him in his iron spider suit because that's the
last suit that he wore in the previous avengers
movie avengers end game but yes rune king thor or
whatever you want to call this new most powerful
version of thor i did a rune king thor video
a couple days ago so i'll add a link for that
in the description below because we got a much
better look at the costumes but the difference
in this preview is that it shows what he'll look
like when he's wearing the full-on helmet in my
other preview he was not wearing the helmet he was
just wearing this new suit this one is inspired
by rune king thor's battle armor from the comics
which is just a mixture of golds and blues you can
see jane foster's thor costume is just designed
to look like a combination of thor's old armors
and comic book female thor with some added red
coloring so that she pops on screen when she and
thor are fighting next to each other on screen and
it gets really crazy marvel does try to make all
the heroes with similar costumes look as different
as possible so that all the really casual fans
don't get confused about who's fighting who
when things get really crazy with huge battles
but as they tease in the shangshi post-credit
scene shang chi is on the new avengers team
that was why wong brought him to the meeting at
kamar taj with the bruce banner hulk and captain
marvel welcoming him to the fold welcome to the
circus you're gonna have to start getting used
to that the trajectory of your lies will be like
nothing you've ever experienced before and there's
no going back we'll probably see shang chi 2
before avengers 5 so don't be surprised if he
also gets another new costume just like spider-man
is getting a new one in spider-man 4. as you can
see bruce banner hulk is still on the team mark
ruffalo not going anywhere there's been talk about
them using the she-hulk series to set up a world
war hulk movie in that marvel has somehow worked
out whatever their problems were with universal
so the things preventing them from actually doing
a hulk solo movie before aren't really that big
a deal anymore we'll probably learn more about
that during the she-hulk episodes later this year
idiots obviously doctor strange is going to be in
the next avengers movie so he's probably somewhere
cut out of this picture just off to the right or
to the left and even though you can't see scarlet
witch anywhere on here kevin feige did say that
she was going to be a huge part of the marvel
cinematic universe going forward so she would
be back for this as well but zoom in enhance on
the new black panther here down in the lower right
hand corner in front of shengshi it physically
still looks like a man so i'm assuming that means
at least without more evidence that it's not shuri
right now the rumor is that during black panther 2
umbacu becomes the next black panther but the
way they're supposedly going to be dealing with
t'challa's legacy because they're not going to
recast the character is that they're saying that
between the events of the black panther movie in
avengers end game at some point before he died he
and nakia had a child together so t'challa will
have a son and eventually he'll become the future
black panther when he's old enough but until then
umbaku will wear the mantle so when we have a big
avengers movie big crossover movie and you want
to see black panther fighting on screen it'll be
m'baku in the costume supposedly they're also
bringing back killmonger but he'll be inside the
ancestral plane it'll sort of be like this
hardcore version of obi-wan kenobi or yoda
speaking to the future black panther
giving them advice from the ancestral plane
somehow force ghost killmonger sounds like a
weird proposition but i'm totally down for it
but over on the left side of frame just a little
cut off you can see miss marvel captain marvel
is also on the far right side and i'm sure monica
rambo is also probably cut off a little here too
but you can see some of the other guardians
of the galaxy that are cut off a frame like
you can see groot next to the new version
of gamora i'm just calling her 2014 gamora
for now so groot for example will also change
form again like they're just showing what groot
looked like the last time we saw him here during
guardians 3 it sounds like he'll be growing into
what vin diesel is just calling his alpha groot
form like the most powerful version groot has
ever been the same way that thor is becoming a
much more powerful version of himself and even
though we haven't seen him in guardians 3 yet adam
warlock would also probably come back for this
the other brand new marvel phase 4 characters they
confirmed but are cut off here like you can't see
in this actual picture are kit harington's black
knight character and cersei from the eternals film
you're ready for that mr whitney speaking of black
knight mahershala ali's blade would also be in the
movie this oscar isaac's moon knight character
we're going to get those episodes really soon
i'll be doing videos for all those episodes just
like all the other marvel disney plus series you
also have a new version of the main loki from the
loki's series you can't do a giant avengers secret
wars movie without bringing back a version of
loki roadie's war machine and iron heart are also
probably somewhere on this mural too and then we
just met america chavez during the doctor strange
2 trailer she'd also be somewhere else on here too
just out of frame but obviously if you're going to
do a secret wars movie you're going to have a
lot of variants and a lot of different versions
of characters like you have the x-men characters
that they're going to introduce in the next couple
of years and the new fantastic four characters
so they'd also be a big part of avengers 5 but
because they haven't even cast those characters
they wouldn't put them on a picture like this
all the characters on this avengers 5 picture are
people who have already been confirmed in cast in
the mcu so far i know a lot of you are asking when
are we actually going to see avengers 5 so we know
all the marvel movie dates through 2025 and what
most of those movies are so all the release dates
are the same for each year there's like a february
movie may july and a november movie starting in
2023 it's the marvels that's captain marvel 2 in
february then there's guardians of the galaxy 3
then ant-man 3 quantumania in the november movie
is probably going to be that new blade mahershal
ali film in 2024 it'll be deadpool 3 the new
fantastic four movie spider-man 4 and captain
america 4 all confirmed films so heading into 2025
they still have four movie dates confirmed but we
only know about shangshi 2 and the new x-men movie
so the soonest they can release avengers 5 is
may 2025 a little over three years from the day
that i'm posting this video so we got a little
while to wait before we're gonna see that film
but kevin feige said they're laying a lot of
easter eggs building towards it the same way they
built towards the first avengers movie in marvel
phase 1 so as we see more avengers 5 clues teasers
easter eggs in the next couple of movies i'll be
sure to point them out in my videos but everyone
click here for my new thor love and thunder first
look video and click here for my new spider-man no
way home alternate ending and deleted scenes video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!